since the dawn of counter-strike the
game has revolved around two guns the
ak-47 and the m4a4 but just a little
while ago for a few crazy months that
all change it comes through beautifully
triple for him and he's gonna close it
out the augmenta helped finish hopefuls
become superstars and brought down
veteran players who failed to adapt
there's no smokes on the cross and all
it took was one tiny price cut how is it
possible that a gun with so much
potential when overlooked for so long
simply put the odd with a buried
treasure hidden in plain sight and the
Auggie's coming out with a POG the
official description for the OGG says
that it's powerful and accurate and also
says that it compensates for it so long
reload times with a low spread and a
high rate of fire so it makes sense that
the Augie is often found in the hands of
new or more casual csgo players with the
rate of the fire on the old wing had it
zoomed in was unbelievably high and it
the patent was even just like a you know
a problem for anybody couldn't you know
offset that if you're in it to spray and
pray well the combination of a high rate
of fire and high accuracy makes the odd
a great choice
basically even a mediocre player can in
theory frag out with the Augie in their
hands and back in February 2014 valve
put that theory to the test
they buffed the gun scope control
improving its accuracy and decreasing
its recoil which in turn led to always
attacking
well it's good I glide after seven days
of god mode tyranny bow brought the
aughh back down to earth
the real nerf to the org is there's no
counts as to these changes you call it
that too inaccuracy spread and you can't
shoot faster than the game allows with
one patch valve has changed the identity
of the weapon but even after the nerves
they remained a pretty good option for
CTS it's amazing scoped accuracy made it
great at hitting mid to long range
targets the issue was that no one was
taking that option at the highest level
players just weren't buying ox why not
well it came down to the guns reputation
be sustainable solution is only appeal
certain you know crusher to your bolio
katana call of duty to start a super
closure the all has many nicknames
it's been called the noob gun the cod
gun the training wheel gun or high
recoil guns too hard for you did you
come from Call of Duty even fear not the
cod gun is for you any self-respecting
csgo player left the aughh in the shop
where it belong and bought something
that they consider to be a little bit
more skill intensive the reason why this
gun is kind of stupid in my opinion is
you can shoot like 10 shots
10 shots is more - enough to kill
somebody with like perfect almost
perfect accuracy not even thinking about
it you just pull straight down no matter
how long you played CS you gravitate
towards two guns the ak-47 on t sine and
the m4a4 on CT side whether you're a pro
or an amateur
that's all you buy maybe I'm not
stressing this enough counter strike has
been aks and m4s for over 15 years it's
been that way forever and the Auburn a
part of the meta it's just never really
been a thing in CSCS or 1.6 even like
the first 6 7 years of csgo
now there are a couple reasons for that
beyond the whole it's a gun for babies
reputation or using the AAG as a crutch
oh I'm only at my rank because my team
is bad yep keep telling yourself though
the all has a 3.8 second reload time
which doesn't matter that much if you're
a pro but could come up
you're ranked games more importantly
though was the $3,300 price tag
now that's only $200 more than the m4
but it was enough to scare a lot of
people away from buying it all with so
few people buying augs most players pros
included just didn't know how to use it
to its full capacity and many didn't
bother learning how I tried to play with
it and I'm terrible with it so I
wouldn't I wouldn't know more I'm just
gonna play them for again but some
people did put in the effort during the
ESL one cologne 2014 quarterfinals
cloud9 pulled out the Agha gainst ninjas
in pyjamas surprising everyone yes an
old on Shan guess and he's making it
work very unusual rifle to be picked up
here in competitive play but at this
range maybe it's work maybe he's figured
something out about this map it's gonna
be a quick triple they will get the bump
line on once again so ni P doing a fine
job driver takes down sean gares
but surprising no one the ball he played
didn't work out for the American team
after that high profile failure the odd
went back to gathering dust in the
background for years that is until
October 9th 2018 when the price of the
rifle dropped to a slightly more
affordable three thousand one hundred
and fifty dollars that's $50 more than
the m4s but I still do think that we're
going to see more Aug usage going
forward if only for the situations where
the scope is gonna be really beneficial
with a few exceptions people were slow
to react most of the community was more
concerned with the changes to lost
bonuses and how that would affect the
game's economy everybody and their
mother released a YouTube video I wrote
a big diatribe on reddit about how it's
either the best thing ever or the worst
thing ever for csgo but that was just
the calm before the storm
a few months later everyone realized
what had happened and the odd was all
anyone to talk about maybe I should have
been using the all gone long chat maybe
you guys are right
while the rifle was nowhere to be found
in 2018 it's skyrocketed in usage in
2019 accounting for 18.1 percent of all
kills and professional csgo matches by
me mark that's almost as much as the off
in the m4 were responsible for at the
time combined suddenly the odd was the
best weapon that CDs had access to and
many teams started buying them in pro
matches but not everyone was on board he
was made up of veteran players like faze
clans still thought the augment legit
and actively avoided buying the gun as
far as phase and particularly Nico was
concerned the odd was a crutch for bad
players and they were never gonna use a
weapon so beneath their skill up but
other teams were ready to adapt and the
all was their ticket to the top 7 we're
gonna do one round of mark this is
absolutely aunts coming back into this
game phase is lost and flitter lee went
from a meme two major grand finalists in
Katowice
and one could argue that their
willingness to give the August hands is
what helped ants bring down the
competition but they weren't the only
ones other teams were all over the
augggh 200 the timing you catch two
players maybe the Treaty jumps it
doesn't matter midday compared to the m4
the aw hi armor penetration less spread
and a versatile scope but it always had
those things the only thing that changed
about it was the price once people
finally bought the damn thing they
realized it was so good that it threw
off the entire equilibrium of the game
it's kind of stupid like there's no
route like it's just so good in every
way it needs to be balanced in some way
which of course meant that many pros
started calling for an increase in price
we just need to raise the price I think
the price would be a bit high Oh
I think the Aubie price changed back to
its original price and on March 13 they
got their wish after letting the
community get a taste of what the gun
could offer valve bump the augs price
right back up to $3,300
I think this is an experiment just to
see how many of us will still play with
the argh I'm also very curious to see if
most pros will go back to the m4 with
this change but the higher price didn't
really did to her anyone from buying it
in fact some pros thought it needed to
be even more expensive or at least give
it some nerves to bring it in line with
other right finally on June 18th valve
nerfed the gun again giving it a
slightly lower rate of fire and a less
accuracy and no one was happier than
Nico who still insisted that the odd was
a low skill weapon but not everyone
shared his enthusiasm for the nerves
so did these changes really kill the
aaaghh in the last few months
the gun is phone off pretty hard but you
have to remember that before 2019 it
wasn't being purchased in pro play at
all so sure it's down to a three point
two percent pick rate on a LAN but
that's a lot better than zero and yet
for a while there it presented a real
viable alternative to the m4 something
no one thought would ever be possible
which is a pretty big achievement for
the
ignored a noob gun it's a shooting
gallery for cyber on top of the
container is incredible
of course the two guns aren't mutually
exclusive they can coexist peacefully
allowing players to experience a more
diverse meta depending on their style of
play so now the question is will we
witness the second coming of the OGG for
the better part of two decades
counter-strike has been about the epic
clash between the a.k and the m4 but now
how the shown a willingness to shake
that up so who's to say that some other
ignored a gun won't suddenly take the CS
world by storm
for example the future looks bright for
the sg553 the terrorists answer to the
all it got a price cut on the same day
as a CT counterpart and it's been
gaining momentum ever since it comes to
a great risk is it worth it at a point
where you are two rounds away from
victory man showing his prowess that
taps with the Creed he's looking for one
of the most brutal aces that we've seen
in recent memory oh that looks so easy
24 16 it has a scope better spread
better recoiled even better armor
penetration than the a K it may sound
crazy but I think that this might
actually be the change that teams should
make so they could actually figure out a
way to counter on and as for the odd
even though it's no longer as affordable
or popular as it once was
it's by no means a write-off look at
this does this is going to be supplying
shooting rotated across to under balcony
and just an absolute turret the odds
moment in the Sun showed us how some
players are too stubborn to change that
the old ways aren't necessarily always
the best and how that can lead to some
incredible Falls and breaks meanwhile it
showed us how young hungry players can
adapt faster and take a so-called scrub
gun to the top the augs journey from
underused the low skill weapon to CS
mainstay is an eye-opening example of
how a little creativity can go a long
way because at the end of the day the
all was beautiful the whole
I definitely did because someone was
calling me hello
you no worries but it's the wrong number
you heard yeah you heard that you heard
that oh man this should definitely
who-who do you think it was